Sledge : Ok les gars, ils sont cinq dans une pièce non définie du bâtiment A.
Ils ont une bombe.
On intervient rapide, simple, efficace.
La recrue pas de connerie, tu restes à l'arrière.
Arrivée sur le site dans 5, 4, 3, 2, 1
Lancement de l'opération ! (Musique)
Sledge : Aller p*tain magne toi !
Finka : Y a personne, on peut y aller.
Frost : Ils arrivent.
Ils sont à l'entrée sud, Caveira tu les contournes ?
Caveira: Bien reçu.
Alibi les hologrammes c'est ok ?
Alibi  : C'est ok.
Pulse, barricade ?
Pulse : Ok
Finka : Zut ils m'ont cramé
Sledge : On sait où ils sont, on y va !
Fuze : Aller bonne chance les boloss, moi je vais là-haut !
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha !
Sledge : Dokkaebi par ici.
La Baguette dans le couloir !
La recrue : AHHH !!!
Frost : Ils s'est pris le piège, bougez pas je pense qu'ils le couvre
Fuze : Ok les gars faites gaffe à vos p'tit culs parce que ça va péter !
Frost : M*rde !
La Recrue : L'équipe je suis coincé, venez m'aider !
Tirez, tirez !!!!
Fuze : Alors il y'a quelqu'un ? Hé non il y'a plus pers...
Frost : Alibi, choppe les par-derrière.
Alibi : Bien reçu !
Dokkaebi : Vous les avez trouvés ?
Sledge par radio : Non, je pense qu'ils sont dans la grande salle mais je suis pas sûr.
Dokkaebi : Ok, je fais sonner leurs portables.
(Vibreur de téléphone)
Caveira : Coucou.
Caveira : Hé m*rde.
Finka : Sledge !
Alibi : Ok les gars je vais avoir besoin d'aide !
Pulse : Ils sont derrière le mur.
Encore, encore !
P*tain de m*rde !
Finka : Défonce les.
Pulse : Pulse pour l'équipe, on a perdu le signal des attaquants.
Frost : Quelqu'un nous reçois ?
La recrue : aaahhHH !
Pulse : Oh p*tain
La recrue : ET BOOM c'est qui La Baguette maitenant ?
*Hop hop hop !*
Sous-titres par : Witix, Camille Jolette et plus autres.